once I was away most of my movies have  been a reflection of things that  happened to me  but in the sense of the fablements it  wasn't about metaphor it was about  memory  sorry I'm late I picked up Mrs fableman  where should I put her  back home  [Music]  do not cry  and I will sing a lullaby  what kind of mood you're gonna make  important than your hobby can you stop  calling it a hobby sound has been  nothing but just respect from you  sir  I don't know what else to do  [Music]  can you help me  I don't want to disappoint you you do  what your heart says you have to  because you don't know anyone your life  the Fable men's rated PG-13 in theaters  and at home now